[Música]
empezamos nuestra sección económica con
nuestro periodista de especializado en
el tema Jorge Hurtado Jorge buenas
noches y bienvenido cómo está hoy Muy
bien muy bien gracias empecemos con
noticias de Estados Unidos porque la
reserva Federal volvió a subir los tipos
de interés el aumento fue en la tasa
clave de 75 puntos básicos y es el mayor
nivel el que ha llegado desde el año
2008 justo cuando el mundo también
atravesaba otra crisis financiera global
el aumento es el tercero consecutivo de
esa magnitud con el objetivo de frenar
la inflación más alta en décadas con
este aumento el rango quedó entre el 3%
y el 3,25%, pero hicieron un Powell
quien es el presidente de la reserva
Federal de ese país adelantó que espera
continuar encareciendo el precio oficial
del dinero que los gobernadores del
banco calculan que va a superar el 4%
para cerrar este año eso significa que
habría dos nuevas subidas de tipos de
interés en las dos siguientes reuniones
que quedan para este año las autoridades
monetarias también actualizaron sus
previsiones económicas para el próximo
año donde esperan un crecimiento
económico del 1,7%, una tasa de
desempleo del 3,9% Y esperan que la
inflación retorne al
2,6% y los tipos de interés se mantengan
en Rango del 3,8% ahora la pregunta es
que se hacen sobre todo los mercados es
si estos aumentos podrían provocar una
recesión económica escuchemos lo que
decía el presidente de la Fed
restaurar la estabilidad de precios
requerirá mantener una postura política
restrictiva durante algún tiempo el
registro histórico advierte contra la
flexibilización prematura de la política
restaurar la estabilidad de los precios
es esencial para asentar las bases y
lograr el máximo empleo y precios
estables a largo plazo Seguiremos en
ello Hasta que estemos seguros de que el
trabajo está hecho
como siempre este dato de la tasa de
interés de referencia en Estados Unidos
es seguida mercados y tiene una reacción
regularmente es negativa precisamente
por los temores de recesión a los que se
enfrenta la economía estadounidense al
continuar está agresiva su vida de los
tipos de interés para tratar de frenar
la inflación Bueno una cifra bastante
dura como lo veíamos Jorge ya habíamos
dicho que Rusia está haciendo la primera
movilización de tropas la gran
movilización de tropas después de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial cómo está
afectando esto la economía bueno los
vuelos fuera de Rusia se agotaron
rápidamente mientras el líder opositor
encarcelado alexei navaldi convocó a
manifestaciones masivas contra esta
movilización según la herramienta de
estadística Google trends que permite
saber la frecuencia con la que se
escribe una palabra en Google las
búsquedas en Rusia de las palabras
boleto y avión se duplicaron desde que
Putin comenzó ese discurso donde
anunciaba esta movilización la región de
belcor que limita con el noreste de
Ucrania es donde más Se realizaron este
tipo de búsquedas según el sitio había
los vuelos directos a los destinos más
cercanos como Armenia Georgia azerbaiyán
kazajistán estaban agotados
completamente en cuestión de horas el
precio de los tickets de avión interno
con destino a la ciudad de fronteriza
pasaron de costar 70 dólares a 750
dólares Rusia cuenta con millones de
antiguos reclutas como reservistas y
este decreto de movilización parcial de
Putin no aclaró Quiénes serían los
primeros convocados lo que se sabe hasta
ahora es que van a movilizar a unas
300.000 personas de una reserva de 25
millones y los habitantes no son los
únicos que se está yendo porque la
embotelladora balcorp anunció la venta
de su negocio en Rusia Así es el
comprador fue arnes Group quienes
pagaron 530 millones de dólares por esta
operación en marzo El fabricante de
envases metálicos sostenibles redujo las
operaciones en sus tres instalaciones en
Rusia tras la invasión a Ucrania y
estaban buscando una venta de su negocio
ruso un nuevo propietario el comprador
es arnes Group un fabricante de perfumes
cosméticos y productos para el hogar en
envases de aerosol que opera actualmente
en Rusia y vámonos a Estados Unidos
Porque la fiscal general demandó por un
fraude a gran escala a Trump y sus hijos
en qué consiste Esto bueno la fiscal los
acusó de sobrevalorar los activos y el
patrimonio del ex presidente de Estados
Unidos mediante una década de mentiras a
bancos y aseguradoras la demanda viene
de la fiscal general del estado de Nueva
York letity a James que les pide una
multa de 250 millones de dólares la
investigación de la fiscal apunta a que
los acusados disminuían ante el fisco el
valor de sus riqueza para pagar menos
impuestos la demanda de talla 200
infracciones por fraude y evidencia como
supuestamente los traumas manipularon
las declaraciones Fiscales de entre el
año 2011 y el año 2021 esta demanda
Busca prohibir a los traumas hacer
negocios en el estado de Nueva York
proscribir a su del mercado inmobiliario
por al menos cinco años y escalar la
investigación al departamento de
Justicia donde precisamente Trump ya
tiene dos causas abiertas Pues ya
miraremos qué pasa con esta causa Jorge
gracias por la información y nosotros
seguimos con el debate
[Música]